.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Zum ersten Mal wieder hier,
Herr Fausch?
Ja,
ich bin zum ersten Mal wieder hier.
Ivo Sasek.
Herzlich willkommen.
* Jubel *
Wir sind das Heil.
Du bist das Heil.
Sag mal: "Ich bin das Heil!"
(Publikum) Ich bin das Heil!
Das Glück der Welt
liegt in unserer Hand.
Hier schlägt mein Herz schneller.
- Pass gut auf, was ich sage!
Du wirst entweder Gott verdammen,
Gott verfluchen,
oder du wirst zu ihm schreien.
Unglaublich! Unglaublich!
Die Leute wollen etwas tun -
sie wollen geben, geben ihr Herz
und werden derart missbraucht.
Wer hier dabei ist
und hier Verbindlichkeit erklärt,
ist in die Armee Gottes eingetreten.
Wir stehen unter Kriegsgesetzen.
Und bevor im ersten Zug
nicht alle Medien gefallen sind,
steht der Goliath noch.
Verstehst du?
Es ist unsere Aufgabe, diesen
Goliath, alle Medien zu fällen.
Sagt mal "Amen"!
- (Publikum) Amen!
Sie kapieren es nicht.
Ich habe es auch nicht kapiert.
Bis zum Tag X
habe ich es nicht gemerkt,
bis ich gemerkt habe: Hoppla!
Da werden ja ... Da werden ja ...
... Lüge und Wahrheit vermischt,
und da wird Missbrauch betrieben,
um eben dem Guru zu dienen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Singend)
Ihr Söhne! Söhne! Söhne!
Er ist einer dieser Söhne.
Aber einer, der ausgestiegen ist.
Wir zeigen
allen Menschen das Geheimnis,
wie man mit einer unbeschreiblichen
Fülle an Herrlichkeit,
an himmlischer Herrlichkeit,
mitfliessen kann.
Eine
normal funktionierende OCG-Familie
ist daher nichts Minderes
als der Himmel auf Erden.
Stimmt das,
was Ihr Vater gesagt hat?
Nein.
Ja, es ist ... äh ...
Es stimmt in diesem Sinn nicht.
Wir haben oft
Zwist und Streitigkeiten gehabt.
Es ist nur so,
dass es tatsächlich ... ähm ...
... irgendwann
ziemlich eingespielt war.
Joschua Sasek
hat die Sekte seines Vaters
erst vor ein paar Monaten verlassen.
Damit hat er
dessen Konzept durcheinandergebracht.
Ich habe mit meiner Frau Anni
elf Kinder auf die Welt gestellt.
Sie sind heute unsere Hardliner,
unsere besten Mitarbeiter
unter diesem Himmel.
Alles, Kla.TV, alles ist von
meinen Kindern gelenkt und geführt.
Mit seiner Familie
gewinnt Ivo Sasek Publikum.
Sie verkörpert die heile Welt,
auch auf der Bühne.
# Und wer sich auflöst
im Gesamten ...
# Wer sich auflöst.
Über 20 Jahre lang
hat das bestens funktioniert.
# ... steht das Ziel.
# Denn nur gemeinsam
können wir den Berg erklimmen.
# Uh-uh.
# Doch dazu
muss unsere Balance stimmen.
Hier sind meine Kinder und
auch eine erste Schwiegertochter.
Winke mal!
Das ist die erste Schwiegertochter.
Die Schwiegertochter und drei Söhne
sind inzwischen ausgestiegen.
Sie erzählen heute von
der anderen Seite der Familie Sasek -
von Gewalt und Teufelsaustreibungen.
Die intensivste körperliche
Züchtigung erlebte ich mit 20.
Das ist erniedrigend.
Ja.
Man lässt es an sich geschehen.
Das ist ... ähm ...
Das ist nur krank eigentlich.
Dann ging es
ins Exorzierverfahren über.
Exorzierverfahren
hiess körperliche Züchtigung?
Körperliche Züchtigung, oft
begleitet von Schreien und Panik.
Die ganze Familie hat nur noch ...
Das waren
sehr traumatisierende Erlebnisse.
Da liegst du am Schluss dann
halt wirklich horizontal am Boden
und steckst einfach ein.
Ich weiss noch: Ich drückte
meinen Kopf auf den Steinboden,
weil ich wusste ... Dann war ich
froh, dass eben dann der Schlag ...
... dass es direkt auf dem Boden,
wissen Sie ...
... dass es dann ... äh ...
... na ja, nicht knallt.
Und dann ...
... kam dieser Schlag.
Und dann knallte es zum Glück nicht,
da mein Kopf auf dem Boden lag.
Sich in dieser Welt zurechtfinden,
die ihm noch fremd ist:
Joschua, der 28 Jahre lang
nur die Sekte seines Vaters kannte.
Er lebt heute allein
in einer Zweizimmerwohnung.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hier oben lebte er bis vor Kurzem:
in Walzenhausen/AR,
im Hauptsitz der OCG,
der Organischen Christus-Generation.
Das Zimmer
hat er mit seinem Bruder geteilt
und ausschliesslich für die Sekte
des Vaters gearbeitet.
Das Schlimmste war, dass ich
meine engsten Mitarbeiter und Teams,
mit denen ich mich gut verstanden
hatte, zurücklassen musste.
Sie haben alles verloren?
- Ja.
Es gibt keine Relation,
die diesen Sturm überstanden hätte.
Wir fragen bei Ivo Sasek
mehrmals für ein Interview nach.
Er lehnt ab.
Einige Fragen
wird er schriftlich beantworten.
Doch er gibt keine Antwort
auf die Frage:
"Warum haben Sie
Ihren Sohn geschlagen?"
In Walzenhausen
nahm damals alles seinen Anfang.
# Bei Jesus, da sind wir geborgen.
# Hüt und au morn,
am Tag und in dr Nacht.
Der ehemalige Automechaniker
Ivo Sasek
beginnt
mit einer kleinen Gemeinschaft.
Ivo Sasek!
Heute füllt er Säle.
Wir rühmen dich als der Herr
über jedem Atom und jedem Molekül.
Das Leben hier unten ist
nicht einfach, um es schön zu haben.
Das Leben hier unten
ist eine Leidensschule.
Auch online ist er präsent
und erreicht so
mittlerweile ein Millionenpublikum.
Wir stehen miteinander
echt an einer gewaltigen Schwelle.
Ich sage:
Wir stehen mitten im Endkampf.
(Singend)
Ivo Sasek ist multimedial präsent.
Ich mache
regelmässig grosse Spielfilme.
Ich bin gleichzeitig Vorsteher
von Kla.TV, S&G, OCG, AZK ...
Willkommen in der neuen Welt!
Jeder hat morgens zu inhalieren,
was mein Vater predigt.
Und ohne das verliert man
den Boden und den Kompass - alles.
Verstehen Sie, was ich meine?
Das mal ...
... gedanklich
in Frage stellen zu können,
war der grösste Schritt für mich.
* Ruhige Musik *
Simon, Joschuas Bruder.
Er war der Erste, der die radikale
Gemeinschaft des Vaters verliess.
Jetzt
sind Sie nicht mehr der Einzige.
Mittlerweile sind Sie
als Sasek-Kinder zu dritt,
die ausgestiegen sind.
- Mhm.
Was löst das in Ihrem Vater aus?
Es ist für ihn halt schon
ein ganz grosser Fleck im Reinheft,
dass diese einheitliche,
schöne Familie,
in der alle
am gleichen Strang ziehen,
kaputtgegangen ist
und dass jetzt
drei ausgestiegen sind.
Simon und seine Frau Mia waren beide
fest verankert in der OCG.
Vor sechs Jahren stiegen sie
nach einer dramatischen Flucht aus.
Er, der als Nachfolger galt,
hat sich mit seiner Familie
von seinem Vater abgewendet.
Für Ivo Sasek ist er seither
ein Aussätziger und einer,
der von Dämonen besessen ist.
Er nannte mich von der ersten Stunde
einen Deserteur,
weil ich von der Kriegsfront
angeblich wegdesertiert war
und zum Feind gewechselt hatte.
Aber ich hatte auf die Seite
des Rechtsstaates gewechselt.
Wenn er das als Gegenseite sieht,
liegt das Problem
eher auf seiner Seite.
Deserteure
erschiesst man in der Regel.
Ja, Deserteure erschiesst man.
Das hat er mir auch so gesagt:
"Deserteure werden erschossen."
Er brachte in den
internen Infoflüssen Bibelzitate,
dass Verräter gesteinigt
und umgebracht werden müssen.
Wir fahren nach Igis/GR,
unweit von Chur.
In der Schweiz und in Deutschland
verbreiten Saseks Anhänger
dessen Botschaften übers Internet,
z.B. aus diesem Wohnhaus.
Hier wird die Wohnstube
zum Nachrichtenstudio
für Saseks Internetsender Kla.TV.
Wir möchten uns das
genauer anschauen,
werden jedoch gleich weggewiesen.
Kla.TV wird
von seiner Anhängerschaft produziert.
Alle arbeiten ehrenamtlich.
Ich gebe nun an
unser Nachbarstudio in Chur weiter.
Vielen Dank
an meine Kollegin in St. Gallen.
Sehr geehrte Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer,
ich darf Sie heute zu einer
nicht ganz leichten Kost begrüssen.
Saseks Sender Kla.TV verbreitet
primär Verschwörungstheorien.
Wir ziehen in dieser Sendung Bilanz
über drei Monate Corona-Impfpraxis.
Über 3 Mio. Klicks
generiert allein dieser Film.
Eine beachtliche Reichweite.
Tragen Sie dazu bei,
dass dieser dringende Weckruf
jeden Menschen erreicht!
Das ist ja auch das erklärte Ziel,
diese Reichweite zu vergrössern.
Und das steht über dem Ziel,
die Wahrheit zu verbreiten
oder eben
der Wahrheit auf die Spur zu kommen.
Darum kann auch ungeniert
irgendeine Fake-News-Sendung,
sogar über die flache Erde,
verbreitet werden,
die über allem steht,
solange sie der Reichweite dient
und der Selbstinszenierung als
Alternativmedium über allem steht.
Das erklärte Ziel ist es,
zur grössten Medienkette
Europas zu werden.
Kla.TV versteht sich auch
als historisches Archiv
der Gegenstimmen,
als Pflichtzeugin
des Zeitgeschehens.
Nachdem Kla.TV kürzlich
die Flache-Erde-Theorie
als Gegenstimme zum
heliozentrischen Bild präsentierte,
machen wir Sie auf eine
weitere Gegenstimme aufmerksam.
Sämtliche von der NASA
veröffentlichten Erdkugelaufnahmen
wurden laut NASA-Mitarbeiter Robert
Simmon mit Photoshop erstellt.
Es ist halt
die ultimative Verunsicherung.
Wenn man damit konfrontiert wird
und es Leute gibt,
die tatsächlich behaupten,
die Erde sei eine Scheibe,
verunsichert das gewisse Leute,
die wirklich nicht gefestigt
oder gebildet sind - wie auch immer.
Ihre Eltern glaubten daran,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe sei?
Meine Mutter glaubt bis heute daran.
Tatsächlich. Und er, glaube ich ...
Es gab eine Phase,
in der er daran glauben wollte
und das vielleicht sogar tat.
Und dann,
glaube ich, schwenkte es um,
sodass er das Ganze mehr
als Opportunist so interpretierte,
um damit Klicks zu generieren.
Und diese Seite
gibt es leider auch bei ihm.
Das musste ich
relativ schmerzvoll lernen.
Ich hatte immer daran geglaubt,
dass er überzeugt ist davon,
was er sagt.
Deutschland im Krieg
gegen Russland - von Ivo Sasek.
Bitte wacht auf, ihr Deutschen!
Wacht auf, ihr Europäer alle!
Im Namen Deutschlands beliefert hier
ein tollkühner Scholzens-Clan
gerade ein Land mit Waffen, das sich
im Krieg mit Russland befindet.
Dieser Clan
gehört darum rechtzeitig vor ein,
ich sage mal,
Nürnberger Kriegstribunal.
Der Dritte Weltkrieg
ist dann eine Realität,
und zwar genau so,
wie er in den satanischen Schriften
vorgezeichnet ist.
Ich sage:
Alle Scholzens gehören rechtzeitig,
frühzeitig vor ein Kriegsgericht,
ein Kriegstribunal wie Nürnberg.
Er sieht sich als Führer
von Gottes Gnaden, als ...
... Herrscher,
aber auch als Prophet.
Also
keine Trennung von Kirche und Staat,
sondern Religion und Politik
sind ein und dasselbe.
Er kämpft für eine Theokratie.
Und in der Praxis ist das auch so.
In der OCG sagt er zwar:
"Gott herrscht."
Aber in der Praxis
kommt er direkt nach Gott.
Er ist derjenige, der direkt auf
Gott folgt und sagt, wie es läuft.
In der Churer Stadthalle
treffen wir Urs Fausch.
Hier drin finden die Veranstaltungen
von Ivo Sasek statt.
Und hier drin habe er gesehen,
wie Menschen seelisch,
geistig missbraucht wurden.
Es gibt schöne Erinnerungen
und weniger schöne.
Ja.
Am meisten steigt mir auf,
wie viele sehr liebe Leute
ich hier kennenlernen konnte.
* Ruhige Musik *
Dort oben schlief man.
Rammelvoll war es dort. Rammelvoll!
Man brachte das Essen mit,
den Stuhl, den Tisch.
Man brachte alles mit.
Das ist das, was mir heute
eigentlich im Herzen wehtut:
wie die Leute freigiebig sind.
Sie wollen gerne etwas tun.
Sie wollen Teil einer Familie sein
und merken nicht,
wie sie missbraucht werden.
Sie kapieren es nicht.
Ich habe es auch nicht kapiert.
Ich gebe zu: Ich wasche ihnen
die Hirne, so wie euch heute,
um zu zeigen,
was Wahrheit und was Lüge ist,
aber auch, wie man Menschen dient.
Er möchte Macht haben.
Er möchte einfach Macht haben.
Das ist einfach so.
Er setzt alles in Bewegung,
damit er diese Macht bekommt
und einen Einfluss
in verschiedenen Szenen bekommt.
Alle werden
von denselben Sektenjägern
mit denselben Beschuldigungen,
denselben fiesen Methoden
hinters Licht geführt.
Ich habe mich aufgemacht.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Jürg Stettler, komm! Kommen Sie!"
Wir sind per Sie.
Ich bitte Sie auf die Bühne.
So wie ich ein Kopf von OCG bin,
ist er ein Kopf von Scientology.
Scientologen, hallo!
Herzlich willkommen!
Hallo! Herzlich willkommen!
* Applaus *
Ich werde am meisten angegriffen,
weil ich mit den Scientologen
im Bund stehe.
Ivo Sasek bittet umstrittene
Organisationen und Personen
auf seine Bühne.
So habe
seine Anhängerschaft die Möglichkeit,
sich umfassend zu informieren.
Ihr kennt die Schlagzeilen
über den Iran.
Sie könnten schlechter nicht sein.
Das braucht eine Gegenstimme.
Zu einem Zeitpunkt,
als wegen dem Atomprogramm
Sanktionen gegen den Iran
verhängt werden,
bittet er den iranischen Botschafter
auf seine Bühne.
Seine Exzellenz Dr. Alireza Salari.
Herzlich willkommen!
Wir haben als Familie beim
iranischen Botschafter der Schweiz
zu Mittag gegessen
und hatten eine super Zeit.
Alireza Salari und seine Familie
waren ganz nah.
Entwickelt der Iran eine Atombombe?
Ja oder nein? Was sagen Sie dazu?
Das müssen Sie uns
schon noch gönnen.
The only country in the region ...
Das einzige Land
dort in dieser Region ...
... which has nuclear bombs ...
... das überhaupt
atomare Bewaffnung hat ...
... is not
the Islamic Republic of Iran.
... ist nicht
die Islamische Republik vom Iran.
It is the entity named Israel.
Sondern es ist das Gebilde,
das sich Israel nennt.
Warum der Botschafter
hier aufgetreten sei,
fragen wir
beim iranischen Konsulat nach.
Auf unsere Anfrage
bekommen wir keine Antwort.
Auch eine mehrfach
verurteilte Holocaustleugnerin
darf hier uneingeschränkt reden.
Sie ist Strafverteidigerin
und hat den Mut eines Löwen,
möchte ich sagen.
Sie ist stärker als ein Mann.
Ich habe nie eine Frau
mit mehr Profil kennengelernt.
* Jubel *
Für das, was sie hier in Chur sagt,
wird sie danach in Deutschland
zu 18 Monaten Gefängnis verurteilt.
Ich denke, sie war
europaweit in den Schlagzeilen.
Herzlich willkommen,
Frau Sylvia Stolz.
Da war ich dabei, das war happig.
Das war echt ...
Ja, das gab mir zu denken.
Es fehlen Feststellungen
über eine unter der Herrschaft
des Nationalsozialismus
vorgelegene Absicht,
die Judenheit
ganz oder teilweise zu zerstören.
Es fehlen
die Feststellungen über Tatorte,
Tötungsmethoden, Anzahl der Toten,
Tatzeiträume, Täter ...
... Leichen
oder Spuren eines Mordes.
Stolz schliesst ihr Referat
mit dem Appell,
es Kindern gleichzutun
und wahr zu sein.
Mit diesen Eigenschaften
schaffen wir es vielleicht,
eine Welt zu schaffen,
in der man die Wahrheit sagen darf,
ohne bestraft zu werden.
Wenn ich mir das vorstelle:
Da sassen 2'000 Leute -
und niemand stand auf?
Nein, niemand stand auf.
Bei Ivo traut sich niemand,
aufzustehen.
Es sei denn,
Ivo sagt einen Kommentar dazu.
Dann klatschen alle.
Stand niemand auf und sagte:
"Das stimmt nicht!"?
Nein.
Ich muss mich auch
an die Nase fassen.
Ivo Sasek wird
für den Auftritt von Sylvia Stolz
auch in der Schweiz angezeigt
und freigesprochen.
Ivo Sasek und Adolf Hitler:
Seinen Kindern empfiehlt er früh,
"Mein Kampf" von Hitler zu lesen.
Warum hat er euch gesagt,
dass ihr das lesen sollt?
Einfach,
weil es zur Allgemeinbildung gehöre
und man es mal gelesen haben müsse.
Er selber war ja überzeugt davon,
dass "Mein Kampf"
direkt nach der Bibel kommt.
Es gab ab 2009 eine Phase,
in der er fest davon überzeugt war,
dass Adolf Hitler
den Rang eines Apostels hat.
Jetzt kommen reihenweise neue Bücher
von hochgradigen Historikern
auf den Markt,
die z.B. von Adolf Hitler
ein komplett anderes Bild zeichnen.
Versteht ihr das?
Du sagst:
"Das darf man nicht mal denken!"
"Das ist ein Teufel."
Ja, und jetzt?
Wenn das einer war, der
gleich nach Jesus Christus kommt,
was machst du dann?
Wenn das einer
vom Rang eines Apostels ist?
Jetzt staunst du mich an.
Ist es verboten, so was zu sagen?
Prüfe es doch mal!
Hast du es geprüft?
Wer hat es schon mal geprüft?
Ich sehe kaum eine Hand. Seht ihr?
Ist er auch ein Antisemit?
Es gab eine Zeit, in der er sehr
undifferenziert gegen die Juden war.
Davon ist er jetzt
ein bisschen weggekommen.
Aber er folgt immer noch
antisemitischen Denkmustern
und antisemitischen Stereotypen.
Ivo Sasek bestreitet, judenfeindlich
zu sein, und schreibt uns:
"Ich liebe alle Menschen gleich -
auch alle Juden."
"Wir sind seit je
gegen absolut jede Gewalt,
gegen jede Form des Rassismus und
Diskriminierung von Minderheiten."
2009 kommt Urs Fausch
zusammen mit seiner Frau in die OCG.
Er steigt nach sieben Jahren aus.
Sie ist geblieben.
Ich bin ganz allein, ja.
Ich bin ganz allein.
So.
Urs Fausch ist Christ.
Er steckte damals
in einer persönlichen Krise
und suchte Hilfe und Erlösung.
Warum ich in die OCG ging?
Na ja,
das ist eine schwierige Sache.
Ähm ... Ich bin vom Herzen her
ein Gerechtigkeitsmensch.
Meine Kinder sagten zu mir:
"Da gibt es einen,
der Veranstaltungen durchführt."
Sie schickten mir seinen Link.
Ich sah mir diesen Link an
und dachte:
"Wow, der hat aber Rückgrat,
wenn er schon in diesen Hallen
über Finanzen und alles Mögliche,
was in der Zeitung steht, redet!"
Und bei ihm
konnten andere auch zu Wort kommen.
Das gefiel mir,
dass andere eben auch mal ...
Im Mainstream
ist das halt wirklich blockiert.
Aber bei ihm
durften sie zu Wort kommen.
Das faszinierte mich:
die Meinung anderer Leute zu hören.
Hinterher muss ich sagen:
"Wie konntest du
sieben Jahre lang blind sein?"
Wegen der bzw. in Folge der OCG
habe ich alles verloren.
Ivo Sasek sagt öffentlich,
dass Leute,
welche die OCG verlassen haben,
die sind ... ähm ...
... Deserteure.
Deserteure
erschiesst man ja im Krieg.
Das sind Deserteure,
und sie sind ... ähm ...
Wie sagt man?
Nicht Leprakranke ... Aussätzige.
Und was macht man mit Aussätzigen?
Man macht
einen Riesenbogen um sie herum.
Mit Aussätzigen
darf man nicht zusammenleben.
Sie haben Ihre Frau verloren?
- Ja.
Auf einen Schlag. In dem Moment,
als ich ging - zack, war es fertig.
Und das tut natürlich weh.
* Sanfte Musik *
Urs Fausch hat damals in das Werk
von Ivo Sasek viel investiert.
Arbeit und Geld.
Man gab sich
in diese ganze Sache voll ein.
Und man machte das praktisch ...
... stundenmässig sowieso gratis.
Wie viel haben Sie denn gegeben?
Viel zu viel.
- Wie viel?
500 Fr. pro Monat.
Über Jahre?
- Ja. Über Jahre.
Und meine Frau war einverstanden.
Wir waren beide einverstanden.
Wir gaben das Geld auch gerne.
Das muss ich dazu sagen.
Ich musste es nicht geben.
Aber wenn man Christ ist, weiss man:
Man gibt den Zehnten.
Man will
ein gutes Werk unterstützen.
Genau das nutzt er aus.
Er nutzt es aus, indem er weiss,
dass die Leute
etwas Gutes tun wollen.
Jeder möchte etwas Gutes tun.
Genau das nutzt er eben masslos aus.
Das Prinzip
von Ivo Saseks Gemeinschaft:
Niemand muss, doch alle helfen.
Seine schätzungsweise 2'500
Anhängerinnen und Anhänger tun alles.
Yeah!
Und alles gratis.
Krass!
Er wickelt sie um den Finger.
Die Leute kommen.
Es wird gefilmt.
Es ist etwas los.
Das fasziniert die Leute.
Aber das ist eben der Köder.
Das ist eben genau der Köder,
weil es eben interessant ist.
Es war auch für mich der Köder.
Ich habe damals
die Zeitung "S&G" aufgesetzt.
Ich war
der Setzer der Spalten und so.
Es ist interessant,
so etwas zu lernen.
Wie viel haben Sie
für Herrn Sasek gearbeitet?
Viel.
Freizeit gleich Null.
Ich habe
30 Jahre lang gratis gearbeitet.
Jeden Lohn, den ich je hatte,
habe ich immer verschenkt.
Und ich habe nie einen müden Heller
für irgendetwas verlangt.
Ich habe seit 30 Jahren keinen
einzigen Spendenaufruf gemacht,
nie für einen Dienst
irgendetwas verlangt.
Dann kommt der Hugo Stamm daher,
ein Sektenjäger.
Dann kommt er vom "Tages-Anzeiger".
Oh, wo bist du? Wo seid ihr?
Ihr Lügner! Was lügt ihr zusammen?
Er erzählt den Leuten
in den Zeitungen,
dass ich ein Geldmensch bin.
Woher nehmt ihr das?
Ich beschwöre euch, ihr Lügner!
Warum sagt ihr einem Ivo Sasek,
er nehme das Volk aus,
er nehme ihnen
das Geld aus der Tasche?
Wo nehmt ihr das her?
Hey!
* Jubel *
Ja.
Halleluja!
Yeah!
Ja!
Wenn Sie 500 Fr. gegeben haben - und
es gibt ja noch mehr Mitglieder -,
was schätzen Sie?
Wie viel kam pro Monat zusammen?
Ja ...
Das kann man ausrechnen.
Zu meiner Zeit
gab es rund 3'000 Mitglieder.
Und wenn man nur schon annimmt,
dass jeder 100 Fr. bezahlt,
pro Monat und Person ... Manche
geben ja nichts, manche sehr viel.
Aber wenn wir einen banalen Betrag
von 100 Fr. annehmen,
sind wir doch bei 3 Mio. Fr.,
oder nicht?
Eine weitere,
wichtige Einnahmequelle:
Im Hauptsitz in Walzenhausen
arbeiten für Ivo Sasek schätzungs-
weise 14 Menschen ohne Lohn.
Mangels Einkommen bekommen sie
Krankenkassenverbilligung.
Jährlich
sind das zehntausende Franken.
Damit unterstützt der Staat
indirekt die OCG.
"Wie rechtfertigen Sie das?",
wollen wir von Ivo Sasek wissen.
Die Frage beantwortet er nicht.
Ivo Sasek gehören allein
in Walzenhausen drei Liegenschaften.
Laut Grundbuch
ist er Alleineigentümer.
Auch dieses Haus gehört ihm -
genauso die Fahrzeuge, die seine
Familie und sein Team nutzen dürfen.
Er gewährt ihnen zudem Kost und Logis
und hin und wieder eine Ferienreise.
Auch das Panorama-Zentrum
in St. Margrethen/SG,
wo seine Filme produziert werden,
gehört ausschliesslich ihm.
Ah, da sind die Stühle.
Mit nichts hat er
die Sekte des Vaters verlassen,
für die er ohne Lohn gearbeitet hat.
Joschua Sasek hat kein Erspartes,
keine Pensionskasse
und kaum Gelder in der AHV.
Was fehlt denn noch im Haushalt?
Na ja,
der Tisch ist schon ein Thema.
Aber ich schaue mir alles an.
Also ein Schrank ...
Ein Schrank ...
... könnte ich auch noch gebrauchen,
glaube ich.
Aber er ist mir fast zu ... gross,
zu sperrig.
Aber Sie haben ja regelmässig
in einem Brockenhaus gearbeitet.
Ja.
- Und wie viel haben Sie verdient?
Ähm ... ein Trinkgeld.
Aber Sie haben dort
ja einen Tag fix gearbeitet.
Mhm.
Ja, es war ...
Es ist so, dass der Ertrag dieser
Arbeit direkt in den Dienst floss.
Halt alle Einnahmen.
All das Geld,
wofür ich gearbeitet habe,
landete letztlich auf seinem Konto.
Und er konnte sich dann
damit etwas kaufen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Seine Kinder würden aus
freien Stücken für ihn arbeiten
und auf Lohn verzichten,
sagt Ivo Sasek.
Joschua hat eine Ausbildung
zum Konstrukteur gemacht
und arbeitet heute
als technischer Projektleiter.
Er kommt langsam an in diesem neuen,
oft noch unbekannten Leben.
So. Das ist doch gut.
Wir wurden so erzogen,
dass die Welt ohne Geld ist.
Dass ... ähm ...
Dass die Welt nicht für alle ohne
Geld ist, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Also ich habe erst gegen den
Schluss, als ich aussteigen wollte,
richtig realisiert:
"Das gehört ja alles meinem Vater."
Man denkt immer: "Das ist uns.
Das ist unser Werk, unser Dienst."
Aber in dem Moment, in dem man
zu viel kritisiert, realisiert man,
dass einem gar nichts selber gehört.
Selbstständig und frei im Geist
sei er heute.
Er verarbeite, was gewesen sei
und nie mehr sein wird.
Man mag seine Eltern ja, das stimmt.
Aber ... äh ...
Damals haben sie schon
auch sehr viel Schaden ...
... äh ... angerichtet. Ich weiss
nicht, ob ich das so sagen kann.
Es fällt Ihnen schwer,
das zu sagen, oder?
Ja.
Ivo Sasek soll einmal gesagt haben:
Wenn eines seiner Kinder
sein Werk verlasse, höre er auf.
Drei Söhne sind ausgestiegen.
Doch er macht weiter wie bisher.
Jetzt braucht es euch. Es braucht
euch alle. Und darum sage ich:
Folgt diesem Aufruf!
Bildet eure Fachgruppen!
Macht den Mund auf!
Stellt euch hin für eine Welt,
die sonst verloren ist!
Ich bin Ivo Sasek,
der 43 Jahre vor Gott steht.
(Schluchzend)
Oh mein Gott, das ist ...
Auch er hofft -
aber nicht auf Ivo Sasek.
Auf seine Frau, die er verloren hat.
- Das ist meine Frau.
Das ist meine Frau.
Wir sind seit 35 Jahren verheiratet.
Ich liebe sie immer noch.
Ich glaube nach wie vor,
dass sie eines Tages wieder kommt
und dass sie diese Sicht bekommt -
das sage ich ganz bestimmt -,
von Gott diese Sicht bekommt,
dass sie auch - wie ich - die Lüge
und die Wahrheit unterscheiden darf.
Aber jetzt
glaubt sie noch an Ivo Sasek.
Ja, jetzt ist sie
natürlich noch voll drin.
Aber das kann man nicht erzwingen.
Das muss von hier drinnen ...
Plötzlich sieht man das.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022